my personal advice if you want to stay
home with your kids if you're young and
you're contemplating career versus being
a mom or like how do I balance those I
think we give people we give women
backwards advice we tell them to go to
college get into a bunch of debt start a
career build a career and then after all
of that then you can think about getting
married and having kids well there's a
bunch of problems with that one is that
you're going to end up having your kids
much older one another problem is you've
got now that you've got this college
debt you want to pay it off so the
thought of quitting your job
sounds because you've got student loan
debt to pay right right